ein bisschen erinnert das ganze
experiment an die story vom planet der
affen in der intelligente affen die
macht über die menschen übernommen haben
ein chinesisches forschungsteam hat
nämlich jetzt menschliche gene in
affenhirn eingepflanzt konkret geht es
um das menschliche entwicklungs gmbh 1
dass das hirn wachstum in menschlichen
fötus reguliert nach angaben der
beteiligten fachleute sind die affen
durch das human geben tatsächlich
intelligenter geworden
kritiker halten das für ethisch sehr
bedenklich ihnen geht dieses experiment
aus china deutlich zu weit ich zum
science fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
die menschliche intelligenz ist nicht
nur ein riesiges rätsel das
forschungsteams weltweit endlich
verstehen wollen es ist auch ein
ergebnis der evolution kurz gesagt
führten immer größeren gehirne zu immer
neuen fähigkeiten irgendwann verließen
unsere menschenähnlichen vorfahren die
bäume gingen aufrecht verwendeten
werkzeuge und schufen die zivilisation
für die ausbildung von intelligenz
machen fachleute unterschiedliche gene
verantwortlich doch auch wenn
forschungsteams in diesem bereich noch
ganz am anfang stehen wird das gehen im
cph einst als ein heißer kandidat
gehandelt vermutung zufolge spielt es
eine entscheidende rolle bei der
entwicklung des menschlichen gehirns
bisher wissen wir dass es unter anderem
zur zellteilung beiträgt und es beim
menschen nach der geburt im vergleich zu
anderen primaten deutlich aktiver ist
dieses gen mcp 1 wurde bei dem aktuellen
chinesischen experiment also insgesamt
elf rhesusaffen eingesetzt dazu einer
der beteiligten forscher ging zu dies
war der erste versuch die evolution des
menschlichen verstands mit hilfe eines
transgenen affen modells zu verstehen
nach der verpflanzung der gene in die
affen gerinne wurden den tieren
verschiedene aufgaben gestellt und ihre
hirnaktivitäten dabei mit einem
kernspintomographen mrt überwacht
konkret ging es unter anderem darum
bestimmte muster und farben wieder zu
erkennen und die ergebnisse sind
überraschend die gentechnisch
veränderten affen schnitten bei einem
gedächtnistest mit bildern und farben
besser als die vergleichsgruppe ab das
forschungsteam schreibt dass es zu einer
verlangsamten reifung der neuronen und
mit einer verzögerten entwicklung des
gehirns kann das gehirn der
manipulierten affen entwickelte sich
also langsamer als gewöhnlich wort was
hast du dich jetzt klüger oder du immer
klüger
der punkt ist nämlich das ist
vergleichbar mit der entwicklung von dem
gehirn menschlicher kinder
diese dauert ja bei uns menschen
überdurchschnittlich lange was sich in
einer sehr langen kindheit äußert das
experiment mit denen laboraffen sorgte
also für eine charakteristische
veränderung ihres hirns und zu einer
menschenähnlichen entwicklung bezüglich
der hirngröße konnten aber keine
unterschiede festgestellt werden das
forschungsteam aus china bezeichnet
dieses ergebnis als bemerkenswert und
betont dass solche experimente das
potenzial haben wichtige einblicke in
die einzigartigkeit des menschlichen
gehirns zu liefern
nur so könnten grundsatzfragen zur
funktion des menschlichen gehirns
endlich beantwortet werden doch das
bisherige studienergebnis ist lediglich
ein kleiner schritt um dem rätsel um die
menschliche intelligenz endlich auf die
schliche zu kommen und auch wenn die
ergebnisse zunächst spektakulär klingen
war das experiment keineswegs auf ganzer
linie erfolgreich denn von den elf
genmanipulierten affen überlebten nur
fünf tiere die testphase zudem kommt
kritik von fachleuten die nicht an der
studie beteiligt sein
die versuche des chinesischen
forschungsteams seien verantwortung
solche experimente würden die rechte der
versuchstiere missachten und das risiko
erhöhen dass bald noch extremere
eingriffe mit ihnen durchgeführt würden
dazu der us genetiker james sie lecker
die nutzung von transgenen affen zur
untersuchung von menschlichen genen die
im zusammenhang mit der hirnentwicklung
stehen ist ein sehr riskanter weg
weitere kritik für diese art von
forschung gibt es auch aufgrund anderer
bedenken nach ansicht einiger experten
und expertinnen besteht die gefahr dass
solche laboraffen vermenschlicht werden
und assoziationen an den film planet der
affen geweckt werden dazu die us
bioethiker jacqueline glover sie zu
vermenschlichen verursacht bei ihnen
leiden wo würden sie leben und was
würden sie machen wir sollten kein
lebewesen schaffen das unter keinen
umständen ein sinnvolles leben führen
kann
andere experten und expertinnen auf
diesem gebiet bezweifeln dass die affen
angemessen versorgt worden sind und dass
die geringe zahl der überlebenden tiere
sowieso keinen
achtbare ergebnisse liefern kann die
aktuelle studie und auch die jüngere
vergangenheit hatte gezeigt dass sich
china auf diesem gebiet der genetischen
modifizierung von primaten einen
technologischen vorsprung geschaffen
hatte hier werden stück für stück die
neuesten dna technologien angewandt
anfang des jahres 2009 10 wurden
beispielsweise fünf klone von genetisch
manipulierten achten geschaffen diese
wurden extra mit einer schweren
psychischen störung produziert um in
dieser thematik weitere
forschungsergebnisse zu erzielen andere
fachleute kritisieren auch diesen
versuch als extrem verstörend in den usa
und europa dagegen ist die forschung an
primaten gesetzlich weitaus strenger
geregelt denn viele fragen bezüglich der
tierethik sind noch unbeantwortet sind
uns menschen nerven so ähnlich dass wir
ihre gehirne nicht verändern dürfen
bleiben sie durch das einsetzen von
menschlichen gehen überhaupt immer noch
offen was sind die gefahren
bahnbrechendes computerprogramm nie
wieder tierversuche anklicken anschauen
und krieg substanzen fitschen abonnieren
der nur hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende naja ihr wisst es ja bis
dann bleibt dran